and breaking today and what is just the
latest example of the less real
psychotic I mean this this is now a
derangement anti-trump rage The New
Yorker now features this cover it shows
the President and Rudy Giuliani
murdering Uncle Sam I don't know if the
mayor's seen it yet
New York former New York City Mayor
attorney for the president Rudy Giuliani
look I I watched you all the years you
were mayor I know you can take a punch
it's not the first time they've taken a
shot at you I want to get your your take
I want to go into the issue of how you
got involved and I want to go to that
Biden tape cuz Biden remember what Nancy
Pelosi said Oh
Trump's guilty of a shakedown using
taxpayer dollars he said that I liberal
Joe okay the illuminants involved in a
shakedown using taxpayer dollars well
that would be Joe Biden short Aysen this
phony charge began with ironically right
with their claiming that the president
threatened szalinski with the cut-off of
military aid of 400 million if he didn't
if he didn't investigate by that's not
true
president didn't do that it's clear
military aid was even on the table then
but that's exactly what Biden did so if
you're going to impeach the President on
some crazy trumped-up excuse the
expression charge that doesn't Biden
have to be investigated and why is it so
hard to get Biden investigator well
let's talk about that when are we gonna
what are we gonna do that mr. mayor I
don't know it's a it's the scandal the
people that are choking America are the
corrupt press and the corrupt Democrats
that have been covering up this
pay-for-play scheme now for two or three
years it's not just one situation it's
two situations millions in Ukraine
billions in China John Kerry son was
involved in the one in China it's not
just one full ad Bulger's nephew
well isn't that extraordinary money from
China goes to whitey Bulger's nephew the
son of the vice president Leonid stepson
of the vice president knighted States
and the son of the
and they're coming after me for
revealing it I should be I should be a
whistleblower I brought out what did
Washington press the corrupt Washington
press has been covering up for two or
three years and to this moment they
believe it's more important to try to
figure out did I conduct the
investigation correctly as opposed to is
what I found not only true but rocks the
foundations of our government when you
have this kind of pay-for-play at the
highest levels remember this is
precisely what Hillary Clinton did with
the Clinton Foundation so there is a
very good question what did Obama know
and when did he know it in December of
2015 the New York Times excoriated Biden
for this conflict of interest having his
son who had just been tossed out of the
military for drug problems put on the
board of the most corrupt company in
Ukraine while he was giving out billions
in the Ukraine mr. mayor you once worked
in the prestigious Southern District of
New York a lot of great lawyers have
come out of there including yourself
Andy McCarthy people on the other side
of the aisle even here's my question
yeah looking at Biden look at it looking
at his son looking what he's admitting
to on tape the case of China he didn't
have any any background experience in
private equity that I could find or
anybody that I know it's 14 days after
he went to China with his dad on Air
Force two and it's a billion five we
have about 35 seconds the Bank of China
was his partner by the way and whitey
Bulger's nephew so that money that 1.5
billion was clearly to buy Joe Biden do
you see the vice presidency
there can't be any other explanation for
it meanwhile Joe was caving in the China
on negotiations about Sakhalin Islands
about tariffs there were reports in The
New York Times about how soft Biden was
on China and now we say hey maybe the
1.5 billion made him a little soft this
is horrible and it's horrible that I
have to go through this to get the press
and even the FBI who was turning down
these allegations that's why the
Ukrainians came to me they said there's
something wrong
in the stands upon my last thing fact
State Department asked you to look into
this sure I got all the memos all the
text they asked me to do it I reported
back to them and they thanked me for the
good work that I did good for you all
right mr. mayor I it's important where
it no is important that's an important
fact surprising important fact
investigate Biden and then investigate
me okay
okay I'll I'll stay on Biden will let
the mob go after you like they always do
then going to happen your whole career